c'est un vaisseau architectural colossal
un triptyque immobilier unique en France
en plein cœur d'Orléans
un produit modulable capable
d'accueillir les plus grands événements
culturels et sportifs
mais pour en arriver là il a fallu 6 ans
d'études trois ans de travaux d'imprévus
et de vie de chantier
[Musique]
ce projet qui
est né d'une ambition
qui est née du fait que sur Orléans on a
besoin d'équipement de cette nature pour
que notre ville notre département notre
région notre pays puisse rayonner
12 septembre 2019
l'ex-président de la métropole truelle à
la main Olivier carré pose la première
pierre d'un projet gigantesque
très vite tractopelle pelleteuse et
toupie à béton entre en scène
les compagnons de Bouygues Construction
s'approprient l'espace entre le bois des
montées et la ligne de tramway
à 70 mètres de haut mais dit prend place
dans sa cabine
il va pendant 14 mois de gros œuvres
portées chaque jour plusieurs dizaines
de tonnes
j'ai compris ça marche
[Musique]
ok ça marche
ils ont pris une grosse grue exprès
parce qu'elle porte en pied de flèche
elle va porter 25 tonnes pour porter
justement tout ce qui est gradins tout
ce qui est gradins préfabriqué qui qui
vont peser entre 6 et 6 et 15 tonnes
certains éléments beaucoup plus
Mehdi et grutier depuis 17 ans alors
être à la manœuvre d'une des plus hautes
grues d'Europe sur le plus grand
chantier de la région ça donne forcément
des frissons
c'est un plaisir parce qu'avant tout bah
du coup on est beaucoup de monde sur les
gros chantiers on est on est pas mal de
compagnons du coup c'est important de
créer une bonne cohésion d'équipe avec
les gars et
ça me plaît c'est gros chantier où il y
a plein de grues parce que j'aime la
grille
au pied des grues justement les travaux
de terrassement sont en cours
d'achèvement mais il faut encore
consolider ce sol situé en zone
inondable
des fondations sont donc réalisées avec
des pieux en béton coulé dans des
cavités d'une dizaine de mètres
sans appliquer cette méthode le terrain
ne pourrait supporter le poids
monumental de l'édifice
deux mois plus tard sur la partie sud du
site les premiers murs sont montés Côté
Parc des Expositions
[Musique]
mon rôle c'est de faire l'avancement que
les gars ne cherchent pas le travail je
fais l'avancement je trace les toutes
les ouvertures je m'occupe de la
ferraille c'est une phase délicate c'est
mieux ne sont pas préfabriqués en usine
ils sont coulés sur place grâce à des
coffrages géants quelques dizaines de
mètres linéaires sont réalisés chaque
jour
là c'est que la branche est habillée
d'une matrice c'est-à-dire un dessin
incorporé à l'avance donc là on doit
être beaucoup plus précis pour que tous
les jours on se reforme avec la matrice
de la veille
ce meurtrier vertical est l'une des
signatures des architectes ils ont
utilisé une pirouette technique pour
valoriser la façade
au gré de la lumière du jour des saisons
l'ombre portée offre une vision
spécifique
[Musique]
avant son corps ça tienne avant avance
avance s'il te plaît
l'hiver se termine pluie vent froid les
compagnons ont souffert des conditions
météorologiques mais le timing est
respecté
à cet instant le chantier est un immense
mécano déployé la ferraille côtois les
échafaudages les coffrages bois
difficile de s'y retrouver quand on
n'est pas du métier
les dalalistes sont sur le pont pour
couler les immenses dalles du hall
d'entrée de la future Arena la pluie et
le vent seront bientôt un lointain
souvenir
bonjour
bon c'est bon on coule demain matin
on vérifie la teammétrie pour être sûr
que cette surface va bien de niveau avec
celle qui a déjà été déjà été réalisé
un homme veuille au bon déroulement de
ses opérations depuis le tout premier
jour c'est Lionel Duclos le grand patron
la tête pensante le super manager
ce qui nous pénalise ça peut être le
vent bon on est on est là dans ces
périodes actuellement à la limite de
l'utilisation de de nos moyens de levage
donc de nos de nos grues bon ce qui est
pénalisant c'est c'est la pluie alors
bon ça dépend des périodes lorsqu'on est
en terrassement c'est extrêmement
pénalisant
[Musique]
des grues installées sur des rails
offrent agilité et mobilité sur le
chantier
elles permettent à ce moment précis de
déplacer des murs préfabriqués en usine
et de les déposer à l'emplacement exact
[Musique]
c'est un assemblage mixte on a la fois
ce qu'on appelle du béton de couler en
place donc au travers de coffrage de
branche donc ça pour les parties qui
sont à l'extérieur et principalement
cintrés et les parties de droite et ça
c'est préfabriqué en pas très loin d'ici
en région Centre à Chartres
coffrage à bancher mur préfabriqué le
béton est omniprésent sur le site et
certaines finitions sont même faites à
la truffe
systématiquement même quand un voile il
est bien coulé le béton il a bien été
vibré il y a toujours des petites choses
à faire comme là par exemple on a mis
des collègues des tiges donc après on va
mettre une carotte on vient le reboucher
c'est une étape indispensable
un silence de mort des pelleteuses à
l'arrêt comme partout en France le
chantier comète est touché de plein
fouet par la covid
compagnons ingénieurs conducteur travaux
150 personnes sont priées de rester chez
elle le chantier stoppé 5 semaines une
éternité dans le BTP
[Musique]
précautions
sanitaires mises en place le chantier
reprend fin avril
le port du masque en permanence là en
plus on a des chaleurs
donc là ça a peut-être un peu compliqué
le chantier tourne au ralenti entre 10
et 20 compagnons sont de retour les deux
premières semaines un chiffre dérisoire
la priorité des priorités c'est avant
tout de reprendre dans d'excellentes
conditions de façon sécurisée et
efficace
[Musique]
on montre à lever ensemble allez on lève
l'épisode covid évacuer le chantier
passe à une nouvelle phase en juillet
2020 une phase essentielle et
spectaculaire la pose de la charpente
métallique du parc des expositions
Philippe vas-y
monte un peu
des poutres en acier de 82 mètres de
long fabriqué en Italie sont déplacés
par quatre grues simultanément pour être
montés sur place au millimètre près
envoyer à gauche
orienter un peu à gauche et ben mater un
peu tous les deux maintenant faut la
sortir des pupitres aller en maths
l'opération est très périlleuse le
risque d'accident bien réel
ça y est c'est dans la poche c'est un
beau chantier oui ça commence à faire
le poids
oui ça fait un beau chantillon on fait
pas tous les jours
[Musique]
à 100 mètres de là dans la future Arena
l'enceinte de 10000 places les travaux
se poursuivent avec le coulage du mur
des étages
nous retrouvons Mehdi dans sa cabine il
n'a pas le temps de profiter de la vue
cette fois il doit rester concentré sur
sa mission du jour heureusement la
technologie est là pour les citer
cette terre sert à regarder partout sur
les chantiers quand je suis pas en
visibilité derrière les murs et surtout
aussi pour mettre
comme ça se passe là tu vois là je suis
derrière un mur je vois pas ce qui se
passe du coup je m'en sers et aussi pour
mettre à l'aplomb juste au dessus des
gars je sais que je suis parfaitement à
l'aplomb ça gage de sécurité et vraiment
une bonne aide à la conduite
j'ai jamais fait un chantier aussi
gigantesque celui-ci et autant médiatisé
j'ai commencé par faire quelques photos
du chantier lui-même parfois avec des
vues sur les sur le ciel sur un beau
ciel et en fait je me suis pris au jeu
j'ai les gens qui me suivent sur les
réseaux qui ont commencé à me faire des
bons commentaires en me disant
magnifique lever de soleil
puis vent froid covid le chantier commet
à tout connu depuis l'automne 2019
mais il manquait la neige elle fait son
apparition début 2021 pour offrir un
spectacle à ciel ouvert
à ce stade la pose des charpentes
métalliques se poursuit
sur les joues des édifices les
habillages extérieurs sont posés
délicatement des tôles ondulées en acier
galvanisés rappelant le fleuve royal
tu reçois ce qui va au fond ça
normalement tu n'as pas encore reçu non
non
pour pouvoir finir au niveau des tôles
après je pense qu'il va nous livrer un
peu de castillage avec
l'un des grands enjeux d'un chantier
hors-norme comme celui-ci et bien sûr la
sécurité
casque bouchon d'oreille gants harnais
de sécurité les compagnons sont protégés
mais le risque est grand avec la pose
des couvertures de toit alors défilés
sont installés
alors le but c'est qu'il ne servent
jamais donc la mise en place est assez
longue l'utilisation assez assez
éphémère mais c'est une condition
indispensable pour pouvoir poser
le printemps de retour les travaux
s'accélèrent tout corps confondu plus de
200 compagnons sont recensés à ce
moment-là
du côté de la reine à la charpente
inversée est en cours d'installation
avec un balai incessant de nacelle
[Musique]
seul souci a dénombré en coulisses à ce
moment-là la pénurie de matériaux
mais cela ne va pas empêcher une autre
opération sensible de se dérouler par
une nuit d'octobre
l'implantation de l'impressionnante
passerelle piétonne
37 mètres de long pour 35 tonnes les
mensurations sont monumentales
[Musique]
préfabriquées en usine elle va relier
dans quelques minutes l'arrêt de tram
spécialement conçu pour comète au parvis
du complexe événementiel
[Musique]
deux mois plus tard à quelques jours de
Noël la grande dalle de béton de la
Reina écoulée
il est 17h le sous-traitant portugais
travaille d'arrache-pied les ouvriers
vont rester toute la nuit pour tirer le
béton à l'aide d'un hélicoptère jusqu'à
l'obtention d'une surface parfaitement
lisse
place un nouveau balai
[Musique]
en haut de l'édifice nous rencontrons
d'inya conductrice de travaux ici tout
est gris couleur râles 716 autre volonté
des architectes
en harmonie entre la forêt de charpente
les locaux techniques en fait tout ce
masque dedans et c'est depuis cette
passerelle technique là qu'on voit
vraiment la le volume que représente
toutes ces tonnes d'acier le rôle de
dinia est très précis elle accompagne
les sous-traitants en validant les
ajustements sur le terrain
alors ici on a un des vestiaires joueurs
avec le parterre central au niveau des
différents joueurs qui vont avoir du
couleur leur casier ici et on peut
rentrer comme ça vous verrez également
les douches donc le parterre principal
ici ou les différents joueurs auront
leur vestiaire et ici les douches
collectives qui sont en cours de faïence
au sein de cet immense équipements nous
retournons dans l'auditorium de 1000
places du Palais des Congrès
ce jour là nous assistons à un petit
moment de crispation lié à la peinture
du plafond
t'imagines si on acoustique on n'a pas
le truc on a une salle symphonique ils
ont mis je rappelle qu'ils ont payé 35
de plus bon donc quand tu veux dire
quand la cantatrice elle sera au milieu
ça a pas marché on va tous on va revoir
un deuxième
des plaques perforées capte le son pour
éviter sa réverbération mais Lionel
Duclos le patron n'est pas satisfait du
résultat esthétique il va falloir
refaire une couche
moi je préfère payer une plus-value pour
que tu fasses ça et qu'on garde la
perforation d'origine
[Musique]
à l'opposé la livraison du parc des
expos est prévue dans quelques jours en
attendant il faut encore installer de
grands rideaux rigides 80 mètres de long
sur 6 mètres de hauteur
ce mur mobile va permettre de
compartimenter le parc des expositions
et d'approître sa mobilarité donc c'est
vraiment un métro mot ici c'est 16000 m²
pour pouvoir être divisé en différentes
cellules qui permet une grande souplesse
dans l'organisation de salon
on a affaiblissement acoustique de 50 dB
quand on assemble les panneaux en fait
les joints permettent d'avoir les
coupures acoustiques et une fois que le
panneau est en place on a un système de
verrouillage
[Musique]
après trois ans de travaux après trois
ans de labeur c'est l'heure des derniers
réglages des ultimes finitions
on a travaillé du coup surtout les tous
les étages et se dire que des zones
touchent à leur pain c'est comme le
fruit d'un travail collectif et ça fait
plaisir de voir que les choses avancent
et que les choses arrivent à la fin
[Musique]
plus on se rapproche de la fin plus plus
on le voit se mettre en place un côté
extrêmement exaltant une certaine
pression aussi parce qu'on a un délai à
respecter mais c'est plus effectivement
une exaltation de de le voir c'est
terminé et bien il a terminé
reste à fêter la fin des travaux avec le
bouquet final
la mise en lumière du complexe comète un
spectacle féerique une ode au voyage
[Musique]
ce bâtiment il va vivre d'une multitude
de vie chaque soir va être différent
chaque événement
ça complètement différent du précédent
comme si les architectes avaient conçu
la phase A du vinyle et bien nous on a
conçu la face B de ce bâtiment et de ce
que vont vivre les gens en venant vivre
un événement au centre
[Applaudissements]
Jacques Ferrier l'un des architectes
bâtisseurs savourent l'instant présent
cette douceur nocturne en rappelant
l'intention initiale
on voit le bâtiment la nuit on voit ses
ondulations mais faut voir que ces
ondulations qu'elles ont été conçues
c'était vraiment l'esprit un peu de la
loi l'esprit de ce climat particulier
qui appelle à cette douceur à ce vélo de
couleur blanche
dans une société qui est à fond dans le
digital qui est un peu dans la
désincarnation du monde
l'architecture on peut pas se contenter
de faire des beaux objets il faut
qu'elle participe d'un plaisir je dirais
corporel à être ensemble
[Musique]